anniversary edition of Miami Book Fair
International we are so proud to be able
to present a super wonderful program for
you again this year and I hope you all
will stop along the way and get your
updated weekend schedule there are some
here and you'll find them in different
places along the campus and while I'm
talking reach into your purse or pocket
then turn off your phone
beat bird whatever no don't even sit
there and play games on it I have lots
of game don't do this just please turn
it off so it does not ring oh I don't
know where to start I think I'll start
this year by thanking miami-dade College
they have been our home
for 25 years they provide us
unbelievable amounts of support they are
wonderful they are the people who are
your uh sure's who are the people that
put up the tents the people that do just
about everything that correspond all
year with our authors that start
planning we've already started planning
for next year
they are wonderful we also want to thank
our community volunteers people from the
community like me who do this just
because we love it
it's part of our soul we have wonderful
program gramming here in Chapman today
and I want to thank you for coming if
you're in the first two rows you might
have to move for the next program but
that's it you can see and hear
wonderfully we are on c-span live if you
can sneak a call to your family they can
watch you
last year I wore sunglasses unbeknown
you know I didn't remember that I had my
sunglasses on this this bright light and
I got two phone calls as soon as I
walked offstage at classes you make
sunglasses so people do watch and they
will see you and they will call so smile
okay there are lots of other
announcements you know to look through
and go to the pavilions those are new
the other two years ago and they are
wonderful this year great music great
culture great art from the different
countries that are in the international
pavilion all the rooms the venues that
have I saw people's programs already
kicked off where they're gonna be I'll
be here then I'll see you later it's
very hard to clone yourself but this is
the one day you would like to I hear a
phone okay so see check their schedule
and decide where you're going to be some
things that may not be listed maybe you
haven't had a chance to read Martha
Stewart is going to be autographing in
the atrium at one o'clock for a
wonderful new cookbook right in time for
the holidays you don't have to cook from
it you could read it that's fine that's
fine oh there's so many other things and
in between programs I'll tell you about
more but first I would like to start
this morning's programming and I would
like to introduce to you Hamilton fish
the president of nation Institute
morning easy introduction Jeremy Scahill
Naomi Klein
so it's a really special honor for me to
welcome two of the brightest stars and
independent media both of whom I am
proud to say our fellows at the nation
Institute where I work in New York City
now before coming to the nation
Institute Jeremy Scahill was a longtime
senior producer and correspondent for
the nationally syndicated radio and TV
show Democracy Now
and he remains a frequent contributor to
that indispensable program Naomi of
course those who follow democracy now
will recognize as a frequent guest
Jeremy reported extensively from Iraq
through both Clinton and in Bush
administration's reported from
Yugoslavia during the 1999 NATO bombing
and spent years covering the downfall of
Milosevic government traveling around
the hurricane zone in the wake of
Katrina in September 2005 Scahill
documented the presence of Blackwater
mercenaries in New Orleans his reporting
sparked congressional inquiry internal
Department of Homeland Security
investigation and led ultimately to the
publication of Blackwater from nation
books his now celebrated investigation
of the growth of private security firms
and their pivotal role in the bush
administration's conduct of the war in
Iraq
jeromy's won numerous awards which he
has asked me not to endlessly enumerate
but they include George Polk award of
Project Censored Awards is one of the
few Western reporters gain access to the
Abu Ghraib prison when Hossein was in
power his story on the emptying of that
prison won a golden reel for best
national radio news story of 2002
they only climb familiar to all of you
award-winning journalists syndicated
columnist author of New York Times
international bestseller the Shock
Doctrine the rise of disaster capitalism
published worldwide in September 2007
the Shock Doctrine is set to be
translated in over 20 languages for
previous book no logo taking aim at the
brand bullies was also an international
bestseller translated to more than 28
languages with more than a million
copies in print a collection for work
fences and Windows dispatches from the
frontlines of the globalization debate
published by picadors was published in
2002 naomi writes a regular column for
the Nation magazine
distributed internationally by the New
York Times syndicate in 2004 her
reporting from Iraq for Harper's won the
James Aronson award for social justice
journalism and in 2004 as well
displaying unusual versatility she
released the take a feature documentary
about Argentina's occupied factories so
co-produced with director avi Lewis the
film was an official selection of the
Venice Biennale and won the Best
Documentary Jury Prize at the American
Film Institute's Film Festival in Los
Angeles she is a former Miliband fellow
at the London School of Economics and
holds an honorary Doctor of civil laws
from University of King's College Nova
Scotia which just shows you that foreign
universities have a particular
appreciation for what we think of as
American journalistic talent I want to
just stress what I think is one of the
most interesting parallel features of
the experience of our two writers today
both of whom have given us monster books
in the world of independent media both
of them wrote distinguished critical
dissents from conventional wisdom both
of these books
who are very successful on their own
merits became bestsellers and both of
these authors and their books experience
the same extraordinary phenomenon which
is that during the life of the book
they moved from the critics gallery to
the mainstage skate hills book became
the essential text for a revaluation of
American involvement in Iraq and a
reinterpretation of the way in which the
Bush administration had prosecuted that
war and the way in which our own broader
themes of foreign policy had been
altered by the particular doctrine in
this administration in the Omi's case an
author who had established herself as
the leading dissenter from the orthodoxy
wrote a book which as events transpired
itself became the essential narrative
for real time to such a degree that
frequently will read in the editorial
pages or hear the news anchors in
contemporary news reporting casually
refer to yet another example of the
Shock Doctrine as capital
opportunistically takes advantage of the
serious economic decline as tremendous
pressure pleasure for me to welcome
naomi klein jeremy scahill to miami
thank you so much him and I'm delighted
to be here I'm always delighted to to
share the podium with my very dear
friend Jeremy Scahill he could tell
started this by asking me whether I had
any paper well he had me brought his own
pen but then you will see why I always
insist on speaking before Jeremy it's a
little deal we have I bring the paper he
closes I'm very very pleased to be here
I'm gonna talk a little bit about the
book and I'm gonna talk a lot about the
bailout if that's okay let's not hear it
for the bailout the trillion dollar
crime scene the 700 billion dollars
stick up I'm just looking at how much
time we have there's a lot to say about
the bailout the Shock Doctrine is an
alternative history of how we ended up
with this Wild West brand of capitalism
what the French call savage capitalism
there's no rules so-called free market
that is imploding so spectacularly
before our eyes we have been sold a
fairy tale a fairy tale version of
history that tells us that this that
this way of organizing societies that is
really has really been a liberation
movement for capital liberating itself
from all the barriers to the
accumulation of obscene profits that's
really the history that we've been
living this counter-revolution against
the New Deal we're told that this this
swept the world peacefully and
democratically because people wanted
these policies of privatization of
deregulation of deep cuts to social
spending what I'm arguing in the Shock
Doctrine is that we cannot understand
how this very unpopular ideology triumph
around the world without understand
the role that crisis has played at every
turn the role that shocks play at every
turn and that's what I mean by the Shock
Doctrine but any other Shock Doctrine is
a political strategy that is deeply
understood at the highest reaches of
power and it is high time that regular
people understood this strategy as well
and by the way I think that we're
catching on as him alluded to and that
strategy is that if you have a set of
very unpopular policies that benefit the
elites but don't benefit regular people
then the only time you can push through
this ideology in in in the the the way
that economists describe as economic
shock therapy pushing it through all at
once I'm not talking about the gradual
approach I'm talking about the big bang
moment the tow the moments when you get
it all through at once like Thatcher's
Britain like Russia in the midst of the
economic crisis in the 90s you need a
crisis because a crisis creates a state
of emergency when we are in a state of
shock we regress we become childlike we
start thinking oh I don't know that Rudy
Giuliani is our daddy and he's going to
take care of us and that really Henry
Paulson is looking after us and we can
trust him that's what I mean by the
Shock Doctrine and there is a window of
opportunity that opens up in the midst
of crisis when we are panicked when we
are focused on daily emergencies when it
is possible to push through these
policies without debate so this strategy
is a democracy avoidance strategy it is
a way to get around democracy even if
you happen to live in a democracy even
if you happen to live in an electoral
democracy so what I do in the book is I
trace the various kinds of shocks the
various kinds of crises that have played
this enabling role since this ideology
began spreading throughout the world it
didn't begin with Reagan and Thatcher it
began with Pinochet in the 70s
Pinochet's Chile was the first
laboratory for Milton Friedman and the
Chicago boys the first place to
privatize Social Security
the first place to introduce a flat tax
policy that the Republican Party in this
country has yet to find a crisis big
enough to be able to exploit although
they are still trying out on their way
out the door they didn't have to find
their way around democracy they just
overthrew democracies in Uruguay and
Argentina in Chile and Brazil and in the
aftermath of those shocks they pushed
through these radical policies and they
got rid of the opponents of those
policies with very real shocks to their
bodies and all of these these three
shocks the shocks two countries the
shocks two economies and the shocks two
bodies formed a kind of a perfect storm
that created that first laboratory for
this violent ideology for this violent
market fundamentalist ideology in the
80s it was the death shock it was the
economic crisis that forced countries in
a state of panic in a state of
desperation to go to the International
Monetary Fund and the World Bank and
meet the market fundamentalists there
who said you're in some trouble you've
got a market crisis well we're not going
to bail you out exactly we might give
you a loan but attached to that loan is
a whole set of measures like privatizing
your phone system your electricity
system your oil your water your roads oh
and you're and you're gonna have to cut
back you're gonna have to cut funding to
education introduce school fees and
health care this is also a violent
process this was a so-called peaceful
period I also look at the role that
economic transitions rapid-fire
political change it changes from one
regime to the next and sometimes it can
be a happy transition like the end of
apartheid or the collapse of communism
but it creates a period of such profound
change that's profound this location
that it is possible to push through very
rapid change all at once and I wrote
this book because I had the experience
of living in a country that had
experienced one of these very rapid
political transitions in the 80s
Argentina this was one of the first
laboratory
for this ideology but what most
interested me about what had happened in
Argentina is that when the dictatorship
ended and democracy came in that period
everyone was focused on the big P
politics on the fact that they could
finally vote on the fact that they were
closing the torture centers and when I
heard from so many of my friends in
Argentina was that they felt that they
had missed something in that political
transition that they had missed the
economic side of it and so they had been
able to overthrow the political regime
but the economic system that had been
imposed with so much violence remained
intact
and then I went to South Africa I spent
some time there and I met a lot of
people who told me the same thing about
the transition in South Africa when they
finally overthrew apartheid and had a
democratically elected government that
brought Nelson Mandela to power in 1994
spoke to many wonderful South African
journalists a third generation and seer
investigative journalist named William
gamma day who said this thing to me that
really resonated with me he said we
missed it and what he was talking about
was the way in which the economic system
of apartheid managed to pass itself on
even under democracy
he said we missed it and that reminded
me of something I heard in Argentina
about what they had missed in their
period of rapid change of their
political transition because of course
the liberation movement in South Africa
wasn't just about the right to vote and
the right to freedom of speech for all
people and freedom of movement it was
about the fact that apartheid was an
economic system as well as a political
system which had dramatically
concentrated wealth in the hands of the
white elite and part of the promise of
liberation was the redistribution that
nasty word about those ill-gotten gains
and that was the platform the economic
platform of the ANC and that's that's
the election they ran on in 1994 but in
the key transition period they locked in
several of the key figures like the head
of the Central Bank and the finance
minister that was part of the deal when
they handed over power and they agreed
to have elections the
going apartheid government said we have
we want to keep our apartheid era
central banker and our apartheid era
finance minister in your new democracy
this is one of the great untold stories
right in Argentina the elect elected
paradis government of carlos menem who
came to power as a man of the people
vindicating the crimes of the past he
appointed the central the head of the
central bank from the dictatorship a man
named Domingo Cavallo and he latin
americans in the crowd they know that
name Domingo Cavallo was made famous
because his last act as central bankers
head of the central bank under the
dictatorship was to nationalize the
debts of the largest corporations in
Argentina including the multinationals
like Citibank like Ford like IBM it was
the parting gift
sound familiar we'll take your debts you
can keep the profits well to reassure
the markets during the debt crisis in
the in the late 80s men am appointed
Cavallo and the market cheered a 30%
increase in the Buenos Aires stock
exchange applauding the return they call
it economic continuity be careful of
people talking about smooth transitions
from corrupt regimes if you want change
if you vote for change you're gonna have
some rocky moments along the way there
is no way to transition from a corrupt
regime marked by illegalities marked by
methods that we have rejected like
torture and not have a few bumps along
the way somehow we have accepted this
idea that you can vote for change but
then you can have a smooth seamless
transition that won't alarm the market
that won't alarm anyone that's how you
get the status quo because the market
votes for the status quo it doesn't want
change and people have just voted for
change and there is no way to reconcile
those two forces without accepting that
it's going to be rocky now I wrote the
book
because this strategy of exploiting
these moments of disorientation the
moments when we're all focused on big P
politics on on who's getting the top
appointments on what was said in the
latest speech on on the pageantry of
politics that we don't read the fine
print
now that strategy only works if we don't
know it's a strategy if we don't know it
is a strategy if we know it's a strategy
it stops working because the whole thing
is about exploiting our disorientation
exploiting our regression so the bailout
well you know colonial rulers European
colonial rulers have this habit when
they finally realized they had to hand
over power to the indigenous population
they would loot the Treasury on the way
out the door the the Portuguese in
Mozambique poured cement down the
elevator shafts they were particularly
vindictive I think that this bailout
should be understood as the Bush
administration's final pillage that is
actually what we're seeing here and it
goes well beyond the seven hundred
billion dollars and it's far more than
seven hundred billion dollars when you
count Fannie Mae and Freddie Mac and
when you count the loans that are being
handed out with no accountability that's
up to two trillion we're talking multi
trillion dollars here and the the it
goes beyond that because after they
finished looting the Treasury then they
then the real crisis begins and that's
the crisis in the public books
that's the transfer of a private
economic profit sector crisis to the
public sector and then all the things
that people have been saying yes we can
about yes we can have alternative energy
yes we can have health care for all
Americans then it becomes in an instant
no we can't sorry we can't afford it
we've just spent all the money we don't
have any
les right so all the people who've been
selling this bailout then become the
naysayers so think about it as
Republican insurance against the promise
of real political change in this country
it only works if we don't know about it
if we don't understand that this is a
tactic now think about that original
three-page ransom note
that Henry Paulson presented the country
with right if you know incredibly
included this clause that said
explicitly that that Treasury would be
given seven hundred billion dollars to
do with what it liked and that the
decisions made under the bailout could
not be challenged by any arm of
government and by any court of law
remember that remember that you know and
in some ways this gives me hope because
people recognize this pattern in that
moment right it was it was a moment of
pattern recognition with we said we
called it the economic patriot act right
we said haven't haven't we seen this
before a moment of crisis and they ran
through this legislation you know the
real mistake that they made was how
short it was for the Patriot Act was
really long people didn't read it until
it was too late
this was three pages and people were
everyone read it
everyone read it but John McCain and
they link to it and they blogged about
it and they said no and the part of it
that was most controversial was the lack
of oversight was this idea of a blank it
was a VI d a-- of a blank check so in
order to get the bailout passed it had
to be pretty significantly reworked and
we were all reassured now that there
were all kinds of checks and balances in
place that there were going to be all of
these people doing oversight but they
weren't gonna be able to do whatever
they wanted now a month and a half later
we find out that while Treasury has been
extremely efficient in handing out two
hundred and ninety billion dollars
already to the banks in these equity
deals and to AIG they have so far not
made any of the key oversight
appointments in other words all this
time nobody
has been watching the store but what's
also important to understand is that
Paulsen has achieved by stealth by what
they call incompetence all right exactly
what he originally tried to do
explicitly which is whatever he wanted
okay with no oversight whatsoever now
this is important to understand for a
couple of reasons
I've they're not just handing out these
equity deals to the bank's you know the
specialty of the Bush administration and
this is where you know mine and Jeremy's
work has really intersected very
strongly has been setting themselves
very ambitious goals and then hiring
other people to do their jobs for them
right these are the outsourcers in chief
they have created a hollow shell where
the government used to be it still looks
like a government still you know they
still play a government on TV but every
part of you know what we consider core
government services has been outsourced
right and Blackwater of course is the
ultimate example and the most
frightening of the example of this
they've run the bailout in exactly the
same way they announced this and it is
the new Trump after Homeland Security
and Iraq the entire thing is being run
by private accounting firms and by the
same banks and this is the same Wall
Street law firms that got us into this
mess I'm just gonna tell you about one
contract that was handed out to a law
firm to advise the Treasury about how to
about these equity deals that they
negotiated with the banks okay they
which they were calling nationalization
and I think we got that wrong I don't
think it's Treasury that national that
nationalized the banks I think it's the
banks that privatized Treasury and so so
you know this is I don't really even
understand why they needed to outsource
this part of the job because if there's
one thing they have at Treasury its
former goldman sachs executives who know
how to it presumably know how to know
how to make these deals that's that's
all they know how to do nonetheless they
felt they needed to hand out a
a contract to a law firm to give them
advice on these deals the firm that got
the deal is called I'm Simpson Thacher
and Bartlett the first test for for the
bailout was that meeting that Henry
Paulson had with the nine CEOs of the
largest banks in the country and they
announced in one hour
that Paulson had strong-armed these
banks into accepting 150 billion dollars
of taxpayer money he's so tough right
well so this was Simpson Bartlett
Thatcher's first gig okay this this deal
now what was interesting when I started
looking into this this one company I
wrote a piece about it for Rolling Stone
you can read it on their website or on
my website
Simpson Bartlett Thatcher has
represented seven of those nine banks
seven of those nine banks okay they are
the quintessential Wall Street law firm
they've negotiated some of the biggest
bank mergers in recent times and maybe
we could say well we want the best you
know we want the best deal makers
available well here's the problem right
taxpayers represent a fraction of the
business that these banks represent -
Simpson Bartlett and Thatcher and the
deal that they helped Treasury negotiate
as we now know is an extremely bad deal
now we were told that they were doing
this that they were injecting you know
twenty five billion in some banks ten
billion and in others in order to
address the credit kind of crunch in
order to get money flow lending floating
right well the first deal in the first
ruling deal making is get it in writing
okay Gordon Brown five days earlier
negotiated to deal with British banks he
got 15% dividends for four British
taxpayers he got seats on the board
voting rights and he got it in writing
that they had to spend the money that he
was injecting that they were injecting
on loans to small businesses and
taxpayers so what did Paulson the tough
guy and their Wall Street law firm get
they got five percent as opposed to
fifteen percent no voting rights no
seats on the board
and they didn't get it in writing that
they were supposed to start lending so
lo and behold the banks decided not to
they decided to pay it out to their
shareholders to pay it in salaries to
pay it in bonuses and to start buying
other banks which will turn around and
say when they get into trouble that
they're too big too big to fail and we
have to bail them out too
um now this may very well be illegal a
lot of what we're finding out now is
that is that this is illegal and you
know we also found out recently that
they slipped in a hundred and forty
billion dollar tax windfall to encourage
these mergers so that's money out of the
pocket of the US government and to put
that in perspective Barack Obama's
alternative energy program is 150
billion okay
that's 100 that just that tax windfall
is pretty much the same amount as the
alternative energy program it the the
health care program is half as much okay
so remember that when we here no we
can't about all the things that have
been demanded and voted for in this
country I'm not going to talk about
treasury except to say that I think
Larry Summers is more of the same he's
one of the people who got us into this
mess and it's the same logic that you
that you you have to sort of coddle this
market that has this personality of a of
an ill-tempered two-year-old who throws
a temper tantrum when anything gets
taken away or changed this is not a
market that needs to be coddled Barack
Obama won this election by telling the
American people something that was true
which is that this is this market
failure is the failure of an ideology
it's the failure of the mania for
deregulation it is the failure of the
idea that you give more and more to the
people at the top and it trickles down
to people at the bottom you know Larry
Summers is somebody who wrote the rules
that created this mess he was Treasury
secretary under Clinton you know and we
all told it we listened to Obama say
this is the
nation of eight years of deregulation no
no no it was not just eight years
glass-steagall which was the law that
prevented investment banks from being in
the same business as commercial banks
that was eliminated in 1999 when Larry
Summers was Treasury secretary he
introduced Bill Clinton when Bill
Clinton signed that piece of legislation
that more than any other created this
crisis he also was side by side with
alan greenspan when they fought to keep
derivatives from being in the reach of
government regulators okay so if you
want change if we really want change it
actually does require doing things that
say there's a new sheriff in town and
the market will react badly and then it
will recover the good news is that we're
a little bit used to these shocks
they're a little bit less shocking and I
actually think there is a moment when it
is possible to patoot to to make good on
some of these promises the closer you
are to the election where the promises
are made the easier it is to do you know
we're hearing a lot about this idea that
we might get a new deal a new new deal
or a green new deal and that Obama is
maybe the next FDR um we subscribe
unfortunately I think to this this great
man theory of history which tells us
that FDR handed the great the New Deal
to us from on high because he was so
enlightened right and we we erase from
so much of our history from so much of
the way we tell ourselves how we arrived
here the this incredible struggle from
below that forced FDR to introduce the
New Deal and that allowed him to sell
the New Deal to the elites in this
country as a compromise because the
alternative for a while there it looked
like revolution and you know Obama has
said many many times that he needs this
incredible movement that brought him to
power to stay mobilized and you know FDR
used to say when people presented him
with a piece of progressive legislation
go out there and make me do it I think
that is
the the the best gift that this
president could be given is a population
that stays mobilize that doesn't just go
home and say it okay we won and relaxed
that keeps reading the fine print that
demands the change that reminds the
Republicans that they lost and you know
it I I think of this as the antithesis
of what I'm calling disaster capitalism
and the Shock Doctrine which is the
exploiting of crisis to get around
democracy to avoid democracy we can use
crisis to enlarge democracy so that it
isn't something that just happens every
few years that it isn't a spectator
sport and and so I think the disaster
capitalists have had the rain for a long
time now and it's time for some disaster
collectivism thank you
now I have to go now I have to go ahead
and say something after this it's a to
shame is fine
last time we were here together in Miami
I believe was was during the FTAA
summit where we were hardly in these
kinds of are you cheering for the FTAA
or for those of us who were in the
streets protesting against the FTA with
this this is a much nicer venue
there's no tear gas or rubber bullets
being fired yet you know a lot of times
when people come to Miami they're they
you know they go to South Beach or
something they're like oh there's P
Diddy or there's LeBron James last night
like Naomi and I was so excited that we
were hanging out with Jane Mayer of The
New Yorker magazine here great we wrote
the great one of the definitive books on
the torture apparatus and the in the
White House and I encourage people to
see her later today with Chris Hedges
and Leila ilaria and others at four
o'clock I want to begin by saying that
I'm really honored to be on this stage
today with with my friend Naomi Klein
she's just an incredible freedom fighter
for democratic movements around the
world as well as the movement to
democratize the media in this country
and I feel really honored to call her a
dear friend I'm gonna begin today by
telling a story that sort of I think
captures much of what has happened in
Iraq over the past more than five years
with the radical privatization of the US
war machine and it's a story that many
of you are probably familiar with to one
degree or another but I'm gonna talk
about some of the details of it the
human side of it that maybe you are not
so aware of and this particular incident
happened a little bit after noon on
September 16 2007 a young Iraqi medical
student named Achmed - Mel Roubaix was
driving in his family's car running
errands with his mother mahasin who was
a doctor and they pulled into a an
intersection in the Monsour district of
Baghdad an area known as nice or square
and at the time that automated his
mother pulled into this square a convoy
of four heavily armored vehicles was
driving down the wrong driving the wrong
way on a one-way street
an Iraqi police officer scram
to try to cut off traffic not to protect
the armored vehicles but to protect
Iraqis from getting too close to the
armored vehicles which often have men
inside them who shoot at civilians who
come too close to them well this young
Iraqi medical student didn't stop fast
enough for the men in the armored
vehicles and one of the gunmen atop one
of those cars fired a bullet and shot
Ahmed - malroux by in his forehead that
was followed then by more gunfire
raining down on the car and the car
exploded with his mother mahasin inside
of it and she burned to death in that
car that kicked off 15 minutes of
sustained gunfire at the end of it 17
Iraqi civilians were dead when including
women and children nine-year-old boy was
was shot directly in his head when he
sat in the backseat of the van that his
father was driving and his father
described running to the local hospital
because he could still feel his son's
heart beating and when he got there his
son was pronounced dead and that man
went back the next day to gather pieces
of his son's skull so he could marry as
much of his body as he could find in the
Iraqi holy city of Najaf the men who did
the the shooting in those armored
vehicles were not active-duty military
and they weren't members of moqtada
al-sadr 'he's Mahdi army they were
private forces deployed to Iraq by a
for-profit mercenary company called
Blackwater and for many people around
the world that was the first time that
they had heard the name of this company
Blackwater I've been investigating them
for a number of years after the killing
of four of their men in the Iraqi city
of Fallujah and I'm sure many of you
remember this on March 31st 2004 when
those four men were ambushed and killed
and burned and dragged through the
streets and strung up from a bridge and
the Bush administration used their
deaths to justify an all-out assault on
the city of Fallujah killing hundreds of
Iraqis forcing thousands of others from
their homes and in many ways it was
really the the day the war turned
because you saw a dramatic escalation in
resistance attacks against US forces
around Iraq
you saw moqtada al-sadr smadi army
rising up and the Iraqis were on the
brink of a
unified resistance movement against the
United States and the spark for much of
it was this collective punishment of the
people of Fallujah in response to the
killing of these four Blackwater men and
in the papers in the u.s. the the
drumbeat for revenge was beaten by the
press who described them as civilian
contractors now I don't know about you
but when I was growing up I was think I
was out of a contractor like my uncle
who installs you know air systems in
high schools he's a contractor he gets
hired he does a job but but civilian
contractor it sounds like they work for
the Red Cross or they're like delivering
you know aid to Iraqis or building
bridges but these guys were former Navy
SEALs former Army Rangers working for a
for-profit corporation and they were
guarding trucks ultimately on a contract
for the largest war contractor KBR and
so their deaths then were used to spark
this massive assault on a city that then
resulted in scores of US soldiers being
killed in fact I was just in San
Francisco recently with the Marines
Memorial Association and met with a man
whose son was killed in the Battle of
Fallujah as many families in this
country have relatives who were the
reason I'm bringing up this story and
talking about Blackwater is that there's
a Blackwater in this context is that
there's some breaking news that came
down yesterday we understand that after
14 months of doing absolutely nothing
the Justice Department is now said to be
preparing draft indictments against six
of the men responsible for the killing
that day their potential are gonna be
charged well hold off a second they're
potentially going to be charged with
manslaughter or assault that could face
five to 20 years in prison 20 years in
prison for gunning down 17 Iraqi
civilians that's the maximum charge that
they could face on the the indictment
that's being prepared right now even if
these six men and it could be three men
or it could be no men because it still
depends in part on Bush's Justice
Department the least just Justice
Department in the history of the United
States to move forward with this
prosecution but even if these guys go
down and even if they're successfully
prosecuted even if they are convicted
what is it actually going to do to stop
this system of radical privatization of
the war machine you see Eric Prince the
owner of Blackwater will
they'll walk around with his cocky look
running this little private army and
he'll pay no price for it
it's always the people lowest down that
get hit with the charges you look at the
the courts-martial that have taken place
in Iraq I believe that no one above the
rank of major has been court-martialed
for any crimes in Iraq it's always the
lowest people The Linde England's the
Charles drainers the generals who
implement the policy no the Defense
Secretary who gives the order for
torture or the Secretary of State who
covers up the crimes or deployed these
private armies they never they never are
charged with anything they're never held
accountable for their crimes you know
when people talk about impeachment a
Nancy Pelosi comes in and she says
impeachment is off the table this isn't
just some rhetorical thing that people
are protesting about across the country
we're talking about actual crimes that
were committed by this administration
and they need to be held accountable
don't they say well it's it's it's not
it's not the way things work in
Washington where you get retribution or
revenge against the party that just left
we haven't had a president like this
before we haven't had an administration
that has committed these widespread
crimes in the in the bull in the brazen
manner that these men and women have
committed these crimes and I think
President Obama should be pressured like
all hell to hold them accountable for
everything that they've done to this
country in the world over the past eight
years
but people talk about how the you know
the Iraq war was a was a failure I mean
now they're talking about the surge that
I mean that's a whole myth and I can
talk about that if people want later the
myth that the surge has succeeded in
Iraq they're paying people not to kill
American soldiers that's hardly a
successful strategy but but that's for
another discussion Bush though has has
won an almost unimaginable victory with
what he has done to the way US wars are
waged we have seen one of the greatest
transfers of public well public money to
the private sector in the history of our
country over the past eight years and
they have looted the treasury but not
just taken it and gotten fat off of it
and sat somewhere they've reinvested our
money in private corporations who have
used our money to build up
infrastructure to the point where some
of these armed contractors have military
forces that could take out a small
national government in Iraq right now I
mean this is this is an incredible
statistic in Iraq right now there are
190 six thousand people working for
for-profit corporations alongside one
hundred and forty five thousand US
soldiers these 196 thousand individuals
work for a network of six hundred and
thirty corporations on the US government
payroll the u.s. spends 2.5 billion
dollars a week occupying Iraq between 25
and 40 cents on every dollar goes to
these for-profit war corporations they
have people who are drawn from a hundred
countries around the world in fact is
probably the most internationalized
conflict in the world and yet I would
challenge someone other than a history
professor of political scientists or
Naomi to name more than ten countries
that have actually been stupid enough to
give Bush their troops as cannon fodder
in Iraq it brought down the Spanish
government Britain has almost none no
presence to speak of Poland has a
handful of troops you don't have any
military or any sovereign nation that
was willing to go along with this farce
except for those that were bribed
blackmailed or cajoled into doing it and
then you have Britain which is the u.s.
poodle and when a cenar was there in
Spain he was the flea on that poodle and
so you had those three
operating the occupation of Iraq so
instead of a coalition of willing
nations Bush and his cronies hired a
coalition of billing corporations and
they turn the entire world into their
recruiting ground and so when the nation
of Chile says we're not going to
participate in the Iraq war
in fact we're on the UN Security Council
at the time of the vote and we say no to
this you say fine we don't need the
Chilean military
we'll just take your soldiers so
Blackwater goes in to Chile and hires
Chilean soldiers to work for Blackwater
on a US government contract in a war
zone as a party to a war that their home
government is against it's a subversion
of the sovereignty of Chile and of
nations around the world and they've
come as I said from a hundred nations
but in the case of Chile and they only
mentioned it briefly it's particularly
perverse because some of the men who
were hired by Blackwater were seasoned
veterans of the Pinochet era and the man
that Blackwater worked with as a
recruiter was a former soldier in
Pinochet's military who also was in the
US military he was a dual citizen that
was the man who opened the Gateway for
the Chileans to go to Iraq
working for Blackwater and this is this
is how they have changed the face of the
u.s. war machine it's not just about
taking our young people and saying to
them if you want a college education
just sign this paper and next thing you
know you're in baku by iran you thought
you were signing up to fight floods as
part of the National Guard next thing
you know you're in the middle of a war
of aggression against the people of Iraq
now they turn the entire world into
their recruiting ground the other part
of this is is the money aspect of it 2.5
billion dollars a week 40 cents on the
dollar according to Henry Waxman 25
cents on the dollar according to the
Congressional Budget Office report that
just came out this money is then going
to these companies like Blackwater which
as I say are using it to build up their
firepower Blackwater over the past
decade from 1998 to 2008 has gotten 90%
of its business through the federal
government they are essentially
subsidized by us and yet when Eric
Prince the owner of Blackwater was
called before Congress he refused to
tell Congress how much money he was
making we pay ninety
of Blackwater's bills and this man has
the audacity to stand in front of the
top investigative body of the Congress
and say it's a private matter how much
money I make no mr. Prince it's not a
private matter when 90% of your money
comes from the American people and US
taxpayers but what they have done with
this money is to build a parallel
infrastructure to the u.s. national
security apparatus one of Blackwater's
newest projects is they've created their
own CIA called total intelligence
solutions and it is headed by three
veterans of the Central Intelligence
Agency one of them and I think the most
disturbing person involved with this is
J Cofer black thirty year veteran of the
CIA cut his teeth working for the CIA in
Africa as well as Latin America this was
the man who ran the CIA's
Counterterrorism Center on 9/11 was in
charge of the hunt for bin Laden and was
at the center of implementing some of
the most brutal and criminal policies of
the Bush administration post 9/11 this
was the guy who ran the CIA's
extraordinary rendition program the
government sanctioned kidnap and torture
program where people are abducted off
the streets of cities around the world
hooded diapered shackled put on a plane
and sent to a third country hellhole to
be tortured while being questioned with
questions often provided by us
interrogators to other national secret
police he was the guy who stood before
Congress and said there's a before 9/11
and after 9/11 and after 9/11 the gloves
come off he also has Jay Maher has
revealed gave orders to his CIA
jawbreaker team to literally chop Osama
bin Laden's head off put it on a box
with dry ice and have it shipped back
from Afghanistan well that didn't quite
work out that way and he certainly
didn't catch Osama bin Laden although he
said a Blackwater executive said
recently that when Osama bin Laden is
caught a Blackwater operative will be 50
feet away from him at the time that he's
captured Robert richer former deputy
director of operations at the CIA is the
number two man at total intelligence
solutions Enrique Rick Prado a veteran
of the CIA's paramilitary division a
Latin America specialist is the number
three man at that company these men with
decades and decades of CIA experience
with extensive knowledge of the u.s.
covert operations sensitive national
security information their careers are
now on the open market for bidding not
just from foreign governments
the US government but also from fortune
500 corporations in fact their
literature total intelligent solutions
literature actually targets fortune 500
and then they expanded it recently to be
Fortune 1000 corporations and they say
we can bring CIA type services to the
boardroom so Blackwater is in its own
words is like a one-stop shop for the
government or for corporations and Eric
Prince says that his company is like the
Federal Express of the u.s. national
security apparatus so we don't want to
replace the post office but when you
really want a package to get some where
do you send it to the post office or do
you send it by FedEx he envisions his
company as the sort of FedEx of the
national security apparatus they have a
maritime division they just recently
deployed one of their 184 foot vessels
to the Gulf of Aden to fight pirates
have been in the news a lot recently
they have an aviation division they have
a domestic operations division they made
70 million dollars off of Hurricane
Katrina I saw them on the streets of New
Orleans when the city right after the
city was flooded
wielding m4 assault rifles Glock 9
strapped to their legs telling me that
they were there to confront criminals
and stop looters it turns out the
Blackwater just simply decided one day
to send its forces into New Orleans with
no government contract initially a
private man who is a radical right-wing
Christian bankroll er of the president
decides one day he's going to send 184
armed individuals onto the streets of a
US city to confront criminals and stop
looters on the eighth day that they were
there it almost sounds like a like a
reverse biblical story and the eighth
day that they were there they they get
this no-bid contract from the Department
of Homeland Security to be the official
bodyguard force for FEMA now I don't
know if FEMA has arrived yet in New
Orleans but Blackwater was certainly on
the streets of New Orleans and and it
was it was in the words of one of our
colleagues it was like Baghdad on the
bayou
where all of these corporations and
Naomi and I were there together all
these corporations that had made a
killing off the killing in Iraq descend
on the US Gulf for disaster profiteering
Blackwater started a whole new division
of the company out of this for domestic
operations because it was so lucrative
not just the 70 million that they got
from US taxpayers they also hired out
their services to wealthy individuals in
fact they weren't they were hardly the
only company down there 180 mercenary
companies pride
security companies descended on the Gulf
I met Israeli commandos that work for a
company called instinctive shooting
international operating I wish it was
funny operating an armed checkpoint on
the streets of New Orleans and they were
hired by a private community and the
private community that hired him one of
the people that that was behind flying
these men in by helicopter and landing
in a park across the street from this
gated community was the guy who told The
Wall Street Journal that if the
demographics in New Orleans don't change
we meaning rich white people are out of
here he's the guy who brought in the
Israeli commandos and deployed them on
the streets of the u.s. city but the
point I'm getting at here is that we are
in the midst right now in this country
of the most radical privatization agenda
in history every aspect of our life is
being privatized we see it in schools
where they defund public schools and
then they say well the schools are
failing so we need to privatize them we
see it of course with the incredible
scandal and crime of the health care
system in this country we see it in law
enforcement where there's a radical para
militarization of law enforcement
through private training entities we see
it in prisons where prisons have become
a for-profit industry in this country
where some states build prisons to
import prisoners as part to boost their
economy and now we see it in a very
Frankenstein way with the US war machine
in Iraq so you could say what Bush Bush
lost in Iraq or Iraq was a failure it
was an incredible success they looted
the treasury they built up the private
infrastructure of these for-profit
companies and you know what that they're
all gonna be on the boards in about 50
something days you know where where did
Dick Cheney where was he hanging out
during the 90s well he was running
Halliburton and he was hanging out at
the American Enterprise Institute and
you met Paul Wolfowitz and run some
these guys when they're not an official
power they go to the parallel government
and they build up until the next time
that they're in power but what's to stop
these guys from freelancing their
foreign policy with these companies
what's to stop Chevron the oil
corporation from just hiring its own
little private army and doing what it's
always done in Nigeria or elsewhere
around the world and raising the stakes
out of a little bit more what do they
even need to bother with u.s. foreign
policy anymore why can't corporations
just have their own policy and and I
think we're heading toward that
direction in this world
I I do want to leave time here for
discussion but I I feel like I need to
say something about Barack Obama and
Blackwater because conventional wisdom
would have it that Obama is going to you
know aggressively go after black waters
but shut these guys down and it's like
the clock is ticking for them I wish
that were the case I will say in
fairness to Barack Obama that he is the
author of the leading legislation in the
Senate seeking to bring regulation and
oversight to this industry and he was
very much ahead of the curve on this
issue unfortunately though Barack Obama
has said publicly that he not only will
not sign on to legislation which is
which exists to ban black water and to
stop the use of these companies armed
contracting companies and US war zones
but that he cannot and will not rule out
using them himself in Iraq Afghanistan
and elsewhere you see the the the
problem here is that Barack Obama does
not have an actual plan to end the
occupation of Iraq his Iraq plan will
downsize it and rebrand it but will
sustain a sizeable presence of US troops
for the foreseeable future he will keep
control of the Green Zone Baghdad
International Airport and the monstrous
US Embassy which was built in part on
slave labor forced labor and Obama is
has written himself into a corner where
he is going to need companies like
Blackwater Triple Canopy and DynCorp to
implement his Iraq policy he also and I
think this is incredibly disturbing is
characterizing Afghanistan as the good
war as meant many of the Democrats
checked their spines at the door during
the Democratic National Convention like
it was a mink coat and they they they're
sort of like vegetarians between meals
they're anti war between elections you
know I could only find one Congress
member brave old Marcy Kaptur from from
Ohio who represents Joe the plumbers
District I love that Joe his name isn't
Joe he's not a plumber and he would have
benefited from Obama's tax plan but and
he's threatening to run against Marcy
Kaptur for Congress but Marcy Kaptur
spoke out about the Afghanistan policy
of Obama and when I said to her what
would you tell Barack Obama she said I
would tell him to pick up the phone and
call the Russians and ask them what
happened in Afghanistan she was the only
Democrat
that spoke out against it now we're
gonna have an escalation Afghanistan and
it's going to get very very bad very
very fast it's gonna predict that
Afghanistan is gonna get worse and worse
as the US escalation is implemented
Obama credits himself with pushing for
more troops and saying that McCain and
Bush followed his lead so we have Iraq
the occupation is not going to end it's
going to be downsized and rebranded
Afghanistan is going to escalate Obama
unfortunately uses the Bush
administration and the Clinton
administration rhetoric on the war on
drugs he talks about the the war on the
people of Latin America so it actually
is a war on drugs it's a
counterinsurgency war and it always has
been yes there's narco trafficking yes
it needs to be combated but the u.s. is
using the war on drugs to wage a
counterinsurgency campaign throughout
Latin America and it's no coincidence
that Blackwater is bidding for a share
of a 15 billion dollar contract to quote
fight terrorists with drug trade ties
and a program that could find them
operating in Colombia Bolivia as well as
in Central Asia Pakistan when Obama says
that he is reserving the right to use
unilateral force inside of any sovereign
nations border I think that that should
all be a sobering reminder of what the
past eight years have looked like under
the Bush administration he is in
posturing aggressively toward Iran and
his statements at AIPAC about Israel
Palestine where I just think atrocious
and and then you look at the people that
he is considering for high posts Naomi
mentioned Larry Summers Rahm Emmanuel
you you can't get a more symbolic a
sense of where this is all going than
the selection of Rahm Emanuel is the
chief of staff they are recycling all of
the Hawks from the Clinton era and
bringing them back into the White House
Rahm Emanuel Richard Holbrooke Madeleine
Albright Tony Lake Susan Rice Hillary
Clinton may be a Secretary of State
Obama had a real chance and has a real
chance to build a foreign policy team
that is not like the 90s where we had
this belligerent policy and the
Democrats were sort of out Republican
the Republicans he has a real chance to
do it but unfortunately it seems so he's
bringing back the old guard and this is
what I think needs to be confronted so
in in closing I want to say that I think
that in a way we've already had a
whoo that's taking place in this country
we live now in a corporatist society the
corporations and we saw this very
clearly in the elections and by studying
the campaign financing corporations are
in total control and I like the way that
that Naomi put it about the the banks
taking over not the other way around but
you know there's that movie usual
suspects and Kevin Spacey has this great
line at the end of it where he says the
greatest trick the devil ever pulled was
convincing the world he didn't exist in
many ways the coup has already happened
and and it's it's it's up to us to
reveal it to confront it it's not about
being Democrat or Republican liberal or
conservative it's about fighting for
what's right in this country the
election is done now the fight begins
thank you
if you if you have a question you may
step to the microphone we have a few
minutes for questions
good morning oh my god I'll step back a
little bit is there any way to reverse
the past 30 years and if so how to both
of you obviously I think we need we need
we probably need four hundred and
something different legislators in the
Congress and a different political
system in this country so I mean I may
be Naomi has a more concrete I think
it's metastasized so quickly
particularly over the past eight years
and is embedded so deeply in every
entity of the federal government that I
I actually think that the only way
really to confront it at this point is
through grassroots action and I you know
as sort of romantic as that may sound I
I put more faith in the people that I've
met in two years of traveling the
country that are out in the streets
regularly than I do in any single member
of Congress
well I mean I do think that that
campaign finance radical reform is is a
huge part of it also you know access to
because I think it is really connected
to the two there part of the reason why
there is so little grassroots activism
in this country and why the labor
movement is so weak it to me it's really
heartbreaking to see so the the unions
pour their money into buying
advertisements for political candidates
on corporate media you know you know on
CNN and and and all these networks and
when think about how that money could be
spent in this moment doing popular
education across this country about
what's really going on with the bailout
right and and and that is a role that
the labor movement used to play is to
really take popular education seriously
and that really that really isn't
compatible with bankrolling the
Democratic Party so it's all
interconnected you know why do you have
to pay money to access the public
airwaves and so I think that that that
should really be the number one push and
when we can make a huge list of all the
things that we'd like to pressure Obama
on but I feel like that's that this is
the demand that makes all the other
demands possible is really trying to
change how the system works and breaking
this cycle but in terms of whether we
can reverse know whether there are
things that can be done to deal with a
financial crisis absolutely and you know
I'll tell you it's not necessarily bad
news to wake up one morning and realize
that you're part owner of the banks you
know that actually can be an opportunity
think about how the International
Monetary Fund responds when countries
come asking for a loan right they come
they have a list of demands and we are
not making any demands of all of these
companies that are coming to Washington
asking for a handout but think about the
demands that could be made about
protecting jobs about alternative energy
about CEO salaries about regulation so
this is actually a moment of opportunity
and when you look at something like you
know the g20 meeting going on right now
just one big photo-op and nothing's
gonna come of it the the think about
what could happen if there was real
leadership and you could be having you
could you could be taxing currency
speculation you could be creating new
revenue sources to pay for your green
new deal right so there so every time
there is a crisis there is an
opportunity to move forward and I'm
certainly not arguing that you know
there's something inherently wrong with
change in the midst of crisis all of
these crises that we're facing whether
it's the economic crisis or its climate
change or it's the fact that we have
more and more wars over scarce natural
resources and more blowback from those
Wars all of these are messages telling
us something that this is telling us
that the system is broken and we need to
fix it and if we think about the history
the progressive history of this country
and the fact that the market crash of
1929 created the institutions that are
now being systematically dismantled in
this counter-revolution we remember that
it is possible to respond to a crisis
with precisely that type of grassroots
activism and demands for real political
change but not you know if we wait for
it to be handed down from on high you
know we're in this moment where we're
finally realizing that trickle-down
economics really doesn't work well
trickle-down politics doesn't work any
better and and I think it would be it
would be a real tragedy if all of that
energy that brought Obama to power like
I said just went home I was asked by the
Guardian what's my advice for the new
president and I said for your base and
the rest will follow but the truth is
that that is a liberation that is not
going to be handed down from on high
it's going to come from below and it's
going to be come from people breaking
free from this idea that change only
comes from elections talk about the role
of let's give other people a chance on
the only house there there's a lot of
people in a short time for both of you
in your opinion how much leeway do you
feel Obama has to make real change in
this country look more more than anyone
in recent memory you know more than
anyone since FDR
they have no one to blame but themselves
from here on end they the Democrats
right yeah I mean the Supreme Court's
going to be the biggest obstacle if if
they really get serious about change but
it isn't just the fact of controlling
Congress in the Senate in the White
House it is it is the crisis itself and
the global demand for change you know we
talk about this economic crisis and this
rejection of this economic model is if
it just began a few weeks ago right but
you know thinking about what Jeremy just
said you know when we were here when we
were at last in Miami together during
the protests against the free trade area
of the Americas well think about that
right I mean that was a meeting in this
city with representative of heads of
states from every country in Latin
America except for Cuba who were all
signed on this was 2003 to the idea of
creating a free trade agreement that
would stretch from Alaska down to Tierra
del Fuego 34 heads of state is there is
there a politician in the Americas who
would publicly endorse the free trade
area of the Americas that's because this
economic model is in such a profound
crisis around the world and those
alternatives are being built in Latin
America they're moving beyond just the
critique and actually implementing
alternatives to what they call
neoliberalism which is the phrase that
they use to describe this economic model
because liberalism means something
different in most parts of the world and
here so you know I think that he has a
lot of leeway born of that international
context as well as the national context
frankly I think there's no excuse not to
move forward I think this is a you know
a once in a you know more than
generation opportunity and and blowing
it would be a terrible tragedy but the
pressure he's under to have the smooth
transition I mean how quickly did it
happen to this celebration of change
this victory for change too but he has
to govern from the middle right but
there has to be you know continuity and
we have to bring in people like Larry
Summers who the market trusts right who
in the market trusts him because they
know he won't do anything
radical as it were so so you know that's
what we're up against
and I think we should be very suspicious
of this fake consensus that is really
about undermining what people have just
voted for yeah I mean I have a little
bit of a different take on it
I mean Naomi is the is the optimist in
this crew I and that's actually saying
something but um you know I usually give
out razor blades when I talk I think
that that we have to rather than sort of
presuming what we think Obama will do we
have to actually look at history because
we have to we have to get away from the
cult of personality analysis about Obama
because I think it it's much more
serious than that and and and the White
House is never about one individual as
Dick Cheney told us it often is about
two people or just Dick Cheney or what
you know however you want to look but
but what we have some historical
analysis that can be applied to this
situation when I mean I talked about in
brief about Obama's foreign policy team
the same can be said for the economic
team the various people that are being
floated around we know almost all of
these people that are being discussed
for four cabinet posts because many of
them already have been there and done
that and done it in a way that really
was devastating to the world the 90s
laid the groundwork for much of the of
the terrible policy making that that
happened when Bush was in the White
House the Patriot Act Clinton laid the
groundwork for it Clinton started the
extraordinary rendition program you had
the targeting of Iraq for the entire
eight years of Clinton's presidency
through economic sanctions and and
bombing you had the the attack on
Yugoslavia the dismantling of that
country you know what I'm getting at the
bad politics toward Haiti is that the
people that are now being brought back
in have a militaristic view of the world
Vince Harding who wrote Martin Luther
King's a speech against the Vietnam War
was saying that this is this is the
issue that separates any comparison of
Obama and Martin Luther King is that
Obama accepts that militarism is a
solution to world problems and that's
why he will never be a Martin Luther
King type figure that's Vince Harding
was saying the other day and I find that
interesting in the context of the idea
that this is somehow an incredibly
unusual situation the Democrats swept
Congress in 2006
we saw what they can do when they have
power in the Congress and that is to get
an approval rating lower than President
Bush that was Nancy Pelosi's crowning
achievement as her time as House Speaker
so III think that that the the forces
that that propelled Obama to victory are
something to take tremendous hope in I
mean I've met so many incredibly
energized people across this country and
I would put my faith in in those people
and in trying to sustain that movement
if the democratic party co-ops co-ops
social movements and swallows them up
democracy has taken a massive hit in
this country we have a real moment and I
think it's a matter of looking beyond
partisan politics and and and fighting
for the direction we want our country to
take so I don't put it as what what can
Obama do as much as what what can we do
and more importantly I think what can we
stop from happening thank you
okay my questions to both of you the
question I'm asking is that right now we
have lots of people that have committed
crimes in the Bush administration okay
and we need to have them you know maybe
be indicted and investigated and the
judicial committee is feeling to do all
of that okay my question is that suppose
okay
Bush uses the nuclear option of blanket
pardon how will we get all of these
people well I mean III like some of the
images that Naomi you know that Naomi
threw out about sort of burning of the
place before they leave it you know I
think that Bush no Bush is going to try
to cover up for the crimes that he's
committed and the crimes that others in
his administration have committed
there's no question and I'm gonna be
very interested to see the pardon list
as he leaves the White House like who's
going to get pardoned for all of their
all of their crimes the reality is I
don't think that the Democrats are going
to are going to go after them in this
way I actually think that the the best
people on this issue are people like
Michael Ratner at the Center for
Constitutional Rights these guys have
been suing Rumsfeld and they plan on
suing Cheney and and Bush in Europe
after they leave office I mean they want
to make it so that these guys cannot
leave the United States or step foot in
Europe I mean you remember the story
when when Pinochet was put under house
arrest in Europe there were these
reports that Henry Kissinger was afraid
to leave the United States because he
was afraid that it would happen to him
if he goes there when Rumsfeld went to
Germany recently there was a major
problem because Rumsfeld was gonna be
slapped with this lawsuit so while we
may have nowhere to go inside of the
United States I would put my faith in
the in the brave men and women who are
the lawyers of the Center for
Constitutional Rights they are going to
pursue these guys like they say they're
going to pursue a bin Laden to the you
know the edge of hell or whatever
they're gonna pursue these guys to the
edge of hell and they're gonna try to
prosecute them and hold them accountable
but I would put much more faith in them
that I would in any official entity in
Washington to do it
well I think it might behoove of us who
has to think of the president's the
president as a high-level middle manager
in all of this and we've just been
through a two-year period of a
presidential campaign where it boiled
down to and with all the murder in this
fevery and everything going on the boil
down to Bill Ayers Joe the Plumber and I
think we have to look at ourselves and
my question is do you think it's time
because the only people who are silenced
during this campaign were the people who
wanted to talk about the war and the
torture and Katrina and everything else
isn't it time for a third party movement
to to take up this wave and move forward
because I don't think the answers are
gonna come out anymore of these two very
sick parties I mean obviously we you
know that not no fundamental change is
gonna happen in this country unless we
break the the duopoly I mean I I totally
agree with you on that but this is a
huge question on how you do that I mean
we saw you know Cynthia McKinney came in
last and she ran on the Green Party
ticket she came in 6th place I think
Nader got 1% of the vote and was the the
highest got the highest number of votes
of any independent running for office
any you know less than 1% basically or
1% in some places I think it's
despicable when people attack people
Ralph Nader for instance for running for
president Ralph Nader has every right to
run for president he did not lose the
2000 election it was stolen and the
Democrats refused to stand up and fight
it in the streets having said that I
think that you know in many ways it also
it can't be trickled down either I think
that you know it has to be the the
battles waged at local levels starting
at school boards and moving up and
trying to get people in the Congress and
this is a long-term fight there are
great activists that are trying to build
it whether it's a third party or it's
some kind of an independent network of
people that are running for offices
around the country obviously we need
that and the fact that that the voices
that you identified the anti-war voices
the anti torture voice is the the people
that are about a real social justice
movement their voices were not heard in
this campaign Obama talked 5% of his
speech is dealt with
Iraq and Afghanistan the New York Times
did an analysis at the end he almost
never talked about these issues and in
fact continued to praise John McCain is
a war hero and to praise John McCain for
standing up about torture that was the
old John McCain the new John McCain
supports that kind of torture but Obama
continued to repeat that so you had no
sense of the of the of the issues that
brought people into the streets
represented on the big stage often times
and that that's a problem and it's a
serious problem but I do agree with you
I think that we need to crack this
system strategically there's a serious
question on how you do that because this
year I think was a pretty clear we got a
pretty clear sense that simply running a
presidential candidate four years is not
the way to build a multi-party movement
in this country there's a widespread
myth that that the dollar is printed by
the federal mint and the government
enters it into circulation when in fact
only banks enter the dollar into
circulation they do it by issuing debt
and the only way to pay it back is by
borrowing more money there's a
documentary about this called money as
debt I was wondering if you could
explain this better than I did and
perhaps make it your next book and if
this isn't the time to take the dollar
which is in essence privatized and
nationalize the US currency so that only
the government can issue money and
perhaps eliminate the fractional reserve
margin is that the way to nationalize
the dollar and end the debt cycle which
is a catch-22 situation well then will
there ever be a time when we can do that
honestly it's not my area and I'm not
going to pretend that it is so I'm going
to treat that as a comment
and encourage you to read my colleague
William Greider is wonderful book about
the Federal Reserve this is his area and
it was interesting we was on a panel
organized by the nation recently built
and bill was saying you know that he
wrote this book I think 18 years ago and
suddenly everyone is you know he there's
been this upsurge of interest and how
the system actually works and you know
I'm pleased to report that sales are
going very well so so rebill Grider he's
been also writing fantastic stuff about
the bailout and the Federal Reserve but
I'm gonna leave it there and we'll try
to squeeze a couple more in hello our
nation used to have a great ethic for
bringing for justice we're doing the
right thing and everyone has a fair
trial and yeah if someone commits a
crime then they should be punished
obviously we have an R in the Bush
administration a criminal criminal
administration guilty clearly of war
crimes and even John Conyers admits it's
not a matter of information it's just
they're thinking about it
yeah so I was wondering why you think
that they are so spineless and unwilling
to do justice for the American people
I mean it's it's a very interesting
question I mean I definitely think the
Conyers had intended to pursue
impeachment at a minimum probably a
wider ranging investigation and I do
believe that the fact that Pelosi laid
it down right from the jump pulled the
rug out from under all of those members
of Congress including some from Florida
who were very Pro impeachment I think
part of it has to do with the way
politics works you know that there's
there's sort of this gentlemen's
agreement that you're not going to sort
of go after people you know after the
fact that they didn't even go after them
while they were in power and that's
that's you know a really serious problem
and on the issue of you know the lack of
prosecutions of these private forces
that have committed all these you know
war crimes Blackwater Triple Canopy
DynCorp like these corporate forces that
have been deployed you know there's a
complete lack of political will of the
bush Justice Department of course
they're not going to prosecute these
guys for war crimes even though they
could prosecute
under the war crimes act but then
there's also the the fact that it would
be bad for business for the war business
if you start going after people for war
crimes that are on your payroll working
as private soldiers in the war zone
you're gonna undermine the whole system
of corporate involvement in the war
machine so and I think that those two
are related the idea of the lack of
prosecution or investigation of the
crimes of this administration and the
lack of prosecution of the crimes of
these private forces I think they all
ultimately stem from the fact that both
of these parties adhere to the same
basic rules of the game and I think I
think that's one of the shameful things
about the political system in this
country interesting that this is coming
up so much now you know I think in some
ways it's you know it's the the euphoria
of the election is wearing off and we're
starting to realize that you know that
yeah they lost the election but they won
a lot and they're gonna get away with it
and there's something really terrifying
and terrible about watching people get
away with crimes on this scale and we're
really we're really feeling the
compromises because they even got away
with it in the campaign itself I mean
this is part of the winning strategy of
not running such a safe campaign you
know how did Obama win this this
election well one of the ways he won was
by giving in on so many important issues
that he never gave the Republicans
anything that they could really sink
their teeth into and that's why they
ended up with you know with Bill Ayers
because he caved on FISA they would have
had a field day with FISA billers was
against it and you know even something
like offshore oil-drilling
you know as soon as it was clear that
that was gonna be a real difference
Obama gave in he said he could see
certain circumstances where that would
be a good idea just like he gave you
know he and he gave retroactive immunity
to the telecoms you know that's another
that that's another example of just
people getting away with these crimes I
was thinking you know the most important
symbolic victory after the elections
will be if Guantanamo is closed right
and I was and that will be that will be
that will be a very very important day
if that happens but this issue of
criminality is you know is central to it
you know one of the reasons why they
haven't closed on Guantanamo yet and
frankly they'd like to is that they're
afraid of the lawsuits that will happen
when they admit that they have been
holding you know hundreds of men there
who are not guilty of any crime if they
are not able to transfer those cases
into criminal courts if they're not able
to normalize or regularize those cases
it's an admission that they have been
torturing people
for nothing okay all of those people
have massive lawsuits so the fact that
the the fact that they did not they're
not going to go after the Obama
administration isn't going to go go
after them doesn't mean that release
prisoners from Guantanamo can't go after
them right and I'm sure you know CCR is
gonna be very happy to represent them so
we have to pay very close attention to
the deals that are made in how
Guantanamo is closed you know are people
being asked to agree not to not not to
sue the government because that's no
kind of victory but they just one
closing thought on this and what window
to you sir you know people talk about a
Truth and Reconciliation Commission what
we need is an actual truth commission
and what the Democrats are going to give
us is the Reconciliation Commission and
that's the problem and you of what
you've said about the bank bailout what
are your feelings about the potential
bailout of the Detroit automakers well
that's being proposed it's not a very
good bailout is once again you know the
the incredible leverage of this moment
is just is not being used and you know
we're not even seeing real demands being
made of the of the auto industry to
protect jobs and or really transition to
to green cars and so I it is more free
money unfortunately but what really
shocks me is the way the Bush
administration is using
his leverage to push through the free
trade deal with Colombia I mean the
cynicism of this is quite stunning and
I'm actually worried there you know for
those of you who don't know what the
Bush administration is doing right now
is holding back on bailing out the Big
Three automakers unless they the
Democrats agree to to ratify this free
trade deal with Colombia okay and you
know this it's interesting because this
is actually one area where there really
was a policy difference and they're just
going after it I'm quite worried that
there is going to be some sort of back
of a backroom negotiation here that's
pretty ugly because of course you know
the the the labor movement in this
country does want the bailout for the
auto makers and they are the reason why
the Democrats have been pretty good on
the Colombia free trade deal so I'm
worried about some horse trading that
could happen very very quickly brokered
by our friend rahm emanuel where
basically they say we'll bail out the
auto makers but and you give us colombia
and and that's you know that is just
nothing resembling democracy so yeah i
hope that answers the question and just
you know just to come back to something
that jeremy was saying and you know
describing so well the creation of this
parallel the infrastructure of the
private contractors this is this this
bailout is completely consistent with
the way the bush administration has
governed that that what we're describing
here is the government that really
treated the state as an ATM right and
and all of these contractors have just
been withdrawing money not even
performing the functions that they said
that they were going to perform like
reconstructing Iraq or and Afghanistan
but just paying back the government in
campaign contributions and now the
bailout really is you know the final
trough and you know one of the most um
you know one of the companies lining up
is Giuliani's law firm you know and they
were you know Giuliani was the first to
cash in on 9/11 for one of the first and
you know I have a quote in this recent
piece that I did where they say the you
know this one's really big
the bad and so you know this is one of
the things that we've been looking at is
you know how each disaster becomes you
know the new opportunity to just loot
the Treasury you had a rock you had 9/11
then you know Katrina and the same gang
shows up and we have to understand that
this is happening again in real time but
it's actually what they're cleaning up
after is the mess they've made of the
economy I think we're gonna have to end
the questions there I thank you so very
much thank you thanks everybody
the authors will be autographing on the
other side of the elevator
campus of miami-dade College and the
home of the 25th annual Miami Book Fair
book TV providing live coverage all
weekend
you'll see many other author lectures
like the one you just saw with Naomi
Klein and Jeremy Scahill we'll also have
open phones and also author interviews
from the c-span bus which is on location
at the Book Fair we hope you'll spend
lots of time with us this weekend
listening to this authors and reacting
learning about their thoughts and
reacting with your own opinions on what
you've heard in fact we'll be opening up
our phone lines for your reaction to
these first two authors in just a couple
of minutes to take your calls to zero to
five eight five three eight eight five
four viewers in the eastern and central
parts of the United States and if you're
watching in the mountain or Pacific time
zones our number is two zero two five
eight five three eight eight six we're
going to ask you to be very careful as
you're dialing those numbers this
morning there are a little bit
complicated five eight five three eight
eight five four eastern and central five
eight five three eight eight six
Mountain Pacific with a 2-0 to area code
we'll be back in just a couple of
minutes to begin your phone calls on
October 15th the National Book
Foundation now